>>Male Presenter: Thanks everyone for coming.
I'm Brad Greene.
I'm an engineering manager here at Google.
I wanted to introduce to you David Kirp.
David is a Professor at the University of
California Berkeley.
He's previously been a Dean.
He was on Obama's Transition Committee.
And he's here to talk to us today about his
book, "Kids First."
And I'll turn it over to David.
>>David Kirp: Thank you for coming.
The inspiration for this project was an attempt
to think about what you'd want for kids in
a society that thought seriously about kids
and wasn't thinking pipe-dream expenses, came
from out of my time that I spent on the Transition
Team.
I was with the Education Group.
There were seven of us and there were probably
200 groups that came.
So, there's the Technology and Education folks,
and the Pre-school folks, and the Child Care
people, and the Native American Head Start
people, and the Compensatory Education Program
in the Catholic schools and the--.
You get the idea.
The Voc-Ed people, all there.
And they were all estimable folks.
But the difficulty was they were all looking
at particular slices of kid's lives.
And there was really nobody that was only
thinking about, talking about, a kid.
So I wondered, putting on my policy wonk cap,
what would a policy look like?
What would a set, a system of supports for
kids from crib to college, or vocational training,
look like?
And so, I traveled around the country.
I had a little bit of money.
And I saw some amazing programs in the most
unlikely places--the Highlands of New Mexico,
and the middle of the barrio in Los Angeles,
and Washington Heights up at the tip of Manhattan--a
tough neighborhood.
And one of my favorite programs is a preschool
in a neighborhood in Chicago that was so tough
that there was barbed wire around the playground
to protect the kids when they were there.
And they were all great programs.
But the problem is they were programs.
They weren't systems.
And that, to this audience, probably makes
particular sense.
If you were lucky enough to be in a certain
place at a certain time and be eligible for
a certain activity, that was great.
But a lot of folks weren't.
And a lot of people, from one age group, children
got great stuff and then nothing else.
So, you might be a poor, single mom with your
first child and you sign up for something
called the Nurse-Family Partnership.
Great, famous program.
A trained nurse comes to you once a week.
A lot of work on child development.
Helps you be a better parent.
Second birthday comes, the nurse and the mom
and the kid blow out the candles and the nurse
is gone.
And there you are.
There you are, a mom, without any of that
support.
And then comes your second child.
And those of you who've had kids, or can think
about siblings, will know that second child,
first child often very different.
The program says, "Sorry, we only look at
first kids."
And I think about a friend of mine from Chicago
who knew a young state legislator turned Senator
named Barack Obama.
And he went to visit him in 2005 in his office.
And they bonded over the classic middle-class
dilemma, "You have kids.
Oh, my God.
Summer camp is over.
School hasn't begun.
What are we gonna do with them for that two-week
time?"
And I thought for a lot of parents, it's not
two weeks.
It's two years or three years or more.
Parents are asking that question and there's
no good answer.
And the final lynch pin for me with this was
an event in New York sponsored by something
called the Dream Foundation.
The Dream Foundation is scattered across the
country.
Provides tutoring and mentoring for kids from
about 3rd Grade on and then supports last
dollar support for college.
It's a great program.
And this girl, who is an NYU student, said,
"I happened to be in Red Hook, 3rd Grade,
Mrs. Ruiz' class, and the Dream Foundation
folks adopted our class.
So, if it weren't for them, I wouldn't be
here."
And I thought exactly, "But if you showed
up the next year in Mrs. Ruiz' class, or you
happened to be in Mr. Brown's class down the
hall, very different life."
Programs, not systems.
And as I started looking at what was out there.
I thought, "What's the encapsulating concept
here?
What am I really trying to think about?"
And the answer was really simple.
This book is about--.
You can encapsulate it in one sentence.
It's the policy version of the Golden Rule.
Every child deserves what you would want for
a child that you love.
Simple, straightforward, and very useful.
So that, for example, there's a lot of attention
now being paid to early education.
Very important.
It's one of my five big ideas, but it's not
enough.
People start thinking about this as the panacea.
You think in Golden Term rules.
Could you imagine saying, "Kid.
We'll have to ignore you until you're three
or four.
You're gonna have a great early education
and then you go off to the untender mercies
of the neighborhood public school."
Probably not.
So, out of that, I came up with an agenda--a
five idea agenda.
Why a list?
'Cause Americans love lists, right?
This is the David Letterman Show.
Rick Perry certainly had his list the other
night.
[chuckles]
We got colleges, US news rankings.
And they're rememberable.
And they're short.
Short lists work.
And I was looking for not new ideas, but tried
and true efforts that could be expanded and
had good basis in evidence and that really
were potential game changers in the lives
of kids.
And the one big idea is if you put them together,
you get a synergy that really reinforces the
effect of any one of those ideas.
So if somebody asks me, "What can we do now?"
I've got answers for that.
What can we do that's really affordable, really
feasible, now?
But ideally, the scheme of some scope, when
I say what you want for a child you love,
I don't mean the Cadillac.
I don't mean that you're giving folks an internship
at the Google campus in this summer and you're
sending them off to Argentina to learn Spanish.
It's really the Kia model, not the Cadillac
model.
But good stuff.
Good, serious, engaging stuff.
And at the end of this book, I try to think
about what "affordable" means.
And I do a little bit of budgeting.
And the easiest way to understand that budget
is if I had--I don't know what the quarterly
profits are at Google.
That might be a better example here.
But if I had a year's worth of Exxon profits,
I'd be halfway toward fulfilling this agenda.
So, what's on the agenda?
Five items.
First, strong support for parents.
I don't know a parent who says, "I don't need
to talk to anybody.
I know everything there is to know about parenting."
And we know how important parents are in kids'
lives.
Not just at the beginning, but all the way
through their lives.
And we actually do know some things now about
what you can do to help parents be the best
they can be.
And my favorite system--on occasion I'm gonna
reference particular programs--there are a
bunch of good programs, like the Nurse-Family
Partnership that I mentioned before.
They're small.
My favorite system is called Triple P--Positive
Parenting Program.
It exists actually here in San Francisco,
in Mendocino.
It's scattered around the country.
Its, in policy terms, one of the world's best
kept secrets.
And it looks like this: First, for 20 years,
the developers of this program asked parents,
"What do you care about?
What are the issues you care about?"
"My kid can't sleep.
My kid can't eat.
My kid cries.
My kid won't listen to me, having trouble
in school, fighting, etcetera"
And then try to develop strategies for addressing
those issues.
And then tested them.
And although the deviser of this program is
a psychologist, he was not interested in one-on-one
strategies.
He wanted to reach parents where they were.
And so, he then turns to everybody to whom
a parent might go--the minister, the social
worker, the principal, the teacher, the pediatrician.
He says, "I'll give you training in these
programs.
It's ten sessions for basic program if you
wanna learn about helping a parent cope with
a developmentally delayed child."
It's another special program.
Training is free.
And then you go out there in the community.
You've got this tool kit.
It's a little bit like doctors who go off
every year for a week or so of retooling.
It's that same kind of effort.
Then, they do a lot of social marketing to
get parents aware of what's happening.
So, the minister says something to them.
You go to the principal to talk about your
child.
The principal says, "By the way, there's this
program that's available if you're interested
in doing it."
And the program is whatever the parents want.
It's everything from pick up a pamphlet to
participate in a ten-week course to, on some
occasions when you have a really difficult
problem, it's some one-on-one or small group
work.
And the data is amazing in terms of what the
impact is.
In this country, the Center for Disease Control
did an evaluation of Triple P and the units
of comparison were eleven rural counties in
South Carolina that got Triple P, and eleven
others that didn't.
That's a huge population base.
And the CDC was concerned about abuse and
neglect.
And it was interested in two measures--hospitalization
of kids in foster care placements, both indicia
of parent's abuse and neglect.
Big, big differences between those communities.
And they would've been bigger still had Triple
P been allowed to use TV ads, which they couldn't
because the TV ads would be seen across counties.
This is new.
And all of anything that I'm saying is quickie
rendering of what's in "Kids First," which
you're getting at an amazing bargain price.
I couldn't get the book at the price that
you have if you're sitting right outside.
So, that's strong parenting . Item two.
Really good early education.
I doubt that I have to say a lot to this group
about why early education matters, about how
important early brain development is to kids.
I do wanna say that it's not what goes on
in an early education program.
A good education program isn't like pouring
a pitcher of water into the--the pitcher of
knowledge into the empty vessel of a kid's
head.
A common metaphor.
Kids are not empty vessels.
They really are explorers.
At 45 minutes, they're looking around the
room and they're beginning to recognize things.
Forty-five minutes after birth.
And at three and four years old, those of
you who've seen and spent time with those
kids, they really are curious about everything.
And you give them things that really will
both satisfy their curiosity and whet their
appetite for more and you've got a teacher
who understands how to be helpful and how
to stand back and let the kids work.
Amazing stuff goes on.
But it's not just cognition that's important.
It's also all those things that go on in a
good preschool classroom--learning to wait
your turn, to share, to not scream at somebody
or beat up on somebody.
"Use your words," as the teachers would say.
All this extra emotional stuff.
And that matters a lot as well.
Not just nice, but it's really, it's important
in terms of lifetime outcomes.
An economist named James Heckman, Nobel Prize
winner from the University of Chicago, had
a large sample of kids who were tested at
age three, both for cognition and for social/emotional
functioning.
And then looked at again at age 18.
And what the data showed was that the kids
who scored really high in cognitive terms
did better in school.
Not as much better in school as you might
imagine, but better.
But the kids who were high on the social/emotional
scale, less likely to be pregnant, less likely
to be in trouble with the police, less likely
to be on drugs or drinking or all those other
things that matter.
So, these so-called "soft" values that pop
up along the way here--good parenting-- and
what it does for parents listening to children.
Good early education.
They really have some hard outcomes.
OK.
Strong parenting support.
Really good early education.
Then three, connecting accurately rigorous
education with all the resources of the community
surrounding it.
We are currently stuck in a debate that I
sometimes describe as Waiting for Superman
versus Diane Ravitch.
Diane Ravitch wrote a bestseller about how
don't blame--.
It's not just the schools.
It's all the surrounding concerns of the social
issues that arise.
And there's "Waiting for 'Superman'," which
basically says the schools are the enemy.
The unions are the arch-devil and charter
schools are the answer.
And that conversation, is it all about blame
the teachers and get better teachers in schools?
Look, hold them responsible and they'll produce
better reading and math scores.
Or, is it in our social conditions that difficulties
of life in the inner city--.
And the answer, of course, is both, right?
I mean, it's this silly kind of conversation.
There's nobody out there who doesn't think
an academically rigorous education--.
Just take that image of Lewis and Clark and
carry it on through.
Children as problem solvers.
All the things that you're asked to do when
you're working on the job--the problems you
need to solve--just imagine them applying
across the curriculum.
That's what you want.
Nobody would disagree with that.
But it's also the case that the model of school
that says you show up at 8, you leave at 3,
you come 180 days a year, just doesn't work
anymore for many, many kids--not just poor
kids, but middle-class kids as well.
Parents are working.
What are you gonna do at 7 o'clock in the
morning?
So, they're working until 5, 6, 7 o'clock
at night.
The community school model says, "We're gonna
start with that academically rigorous school
as the core and we're gonna work around that."
So, there are programs that have hot breakfast
in the morning.
And teachers are there to help kids with their
homework.
After school, all those things that have been
squeezed out of the public schools because
of the high stakes testing in literacy and
numeracy.
All those things you don't get very much of
go on after school.
So, science and history and social studies
and art and music and gym.
You know, gym is really interesting.
I discovered that the typical school now has
a gym class one day a week.
Well, we also have an obesity epidemic.
Somebody has failed to put those two parts
of the puzzle together.
But you want all that kind of activity going
on after school for kids.
You wanna figure out a way of engaging parents.
You also wanna bring the health services into
the schools.
I mean, it's great that all kids are now entitled
to health care through the Children's Health
Insurance Program.
But being entitled and having a doc is something
very different.
And as some of you who have kids know, if
your child needs to go to the doctor, you've
gotta take half a day off from work to make
the appointment and go to the doctor, etc.
So, move the public health programs, move
some of the doctors into the schools.
Provide that kind of service for the kids
and by the way, why not make it open to the
families in the community as well?
Why not open the school generally to the families
in the community of the school?
Make it a real community school.
So, this also might just sound like nice stuff,
but it's not.
I mean, it's much more than that.
Start with health.
About a third of the kids in the typical city
come to school with uncorrected vision problems.
About a third of the kids come to school with
untreated dental problems.
And I don't mean they haven't been to have
their teeth cleaned in the last six months.
These are kids who are in such pain that they
lose a million and a half days a school year--are
lost to dental pain.
And about 30 percent of the kids have untreated
asthma.
So think about it.
If you come to school and you can't read the
blackboard and you're in pain, you're having
a hard time breathing, being able to pass
that high stakes test in 3rd grade where you
gotta write three paragraph essays and read
a complicated passage and some non-fiction
text and some answer some ques-.
It's hard to keep your mind on that stuff
if you're having a difficult time.
After school?
Well, what we know is that the number of hours
that teenagers spend unsupervised after school
is a better predictor of school dropouts than
race or social class.
So, being connected also, you know, why?
Because the kids get much more engaged in
school.
They connect.
And it's not just the skill and drill part
of the world.
It's the fun part of the world.
And summers?
Well, it turns out that kids from across the
social spectrum make about the same progress
academically during the course of the school
year.
It's in the summers that the differences emerge
'cause middle-class families are scheduling
their kids with a fancy dance card.
But poor families?
I mean, those kids are hanging out on the
streets.
So, that's strong parenting support, good
early education, connect school and community.
Four.
Get a caring, stable adult.
A champion in kid's lives.
When I would talk to people who work with
kids, I would hear this phrase "caring, stable
adult" so much that I thought maybe this was
a talking point, right?
Somehow like--.
But it's not.
You think back on your own lives and how you
got here.
None of you made it on your own.
You all had somebody--not just a parent--who
was there for you in some way.
It was a teacher.
It was a coach.
It was a minister.
It was the neighbor.
In the case of the guy who runs a program
called Experience Corps, which is one of the
really good mentoring programs.
It was the barber.
Somebody who went out of their way.
Somebody who could inspire you, could guide
you, could support you.
The best of those systems is Big Brothers
Big Sisters.
Been around for a century.
Reaching about a half a million kids.
And also, an evidence-based program, when
they've studied kids in that program compared
to a control group of students, what they
found is more engaged, happier, doing better
in school.
The big effect?
Better relations with their own parents.
And that surprised me at first.
And then I thought, "We're talking about teenagers."
Now, for teenagers to have somebody else to
connect to, some other adult who can show
them alternative possibilities, other ways
of being and who doesn't have all that charge
of being a parent, well, it takes a lot of
pressure off.
And it gives this kid someone else to talk
to.
And that's item four on the list.
And number five, finally, is probably the
only item that's not gonna be familiar to
you.
And that's a children's savings account.
The program that existed in Britain for about
ten years and that's been introduced in Congress
for many years--bipartisan support one of
the last times it was introduced--its supporters,
its co-signers were Charles Schumer, liberal
Democrat from New York, and Rick Santorum,
then Senator from Pennsylvania--a Conservative
guy.
The model is this: Every child, every newborn,
gets five hundred dollars deposited in an
investment account at birth.
For poor and near-poor families, the government
makes an additional offer.
If you, parents, or family, or anyone contribute
more money to this account, we'll match it
up to five hundred dollars a year.
So, why does this matter?
Well, the obvious thing is there's gonna be
a nest egg.
The miracles of compound interest mean that
you're gonna get a fair chunk of money if
a thousand dollars is going into an investment
account.
And a lot of kids, poor and working-class
kids are very, very good at thinking about
short term costs.
They look at the sticker price of colleges
and say, "I can't go there."
And the result of that in really highly technical
language is that poor, smart kids have about
the same chance of going to college as dumb,
rich kids.
Money helps equalize that situation.
So does savvy, because the other thing that
child's savings account does is it changes
the dynamic of families.
Poor families start getting interested in
their kid’s futures because they see them
has having futures.
And the kids themselves become more money
aware.
Banks are always--the Federal Reserve is always
talking about "what can you do to make kids
more money smart?"
Well, this program does it.
When I've looked at what happens when you
give kids a matching kid's savings account,
they know a whole lot more because now they've
got some money to be smart about.
Those statements are coming in every quarter.
By the time those kids are seven, eight, nine,
ten, they're gonna begin looking at them and
seeing what's happening to their money and
talking about the dollars they have.
When they've done these little studies, kids
are told, "We'll match up to whatever amount
of money, money that you save."
The results are pretty amazing.
I always thought about teenagers as little
hedonists, but in fact, they turn out to be
little Puritans.
They save a ton 'cause they do see what down
the road looks like.
So, what you have is five pillars of support
that carry you from the time you're born to
helping your parents do the best they can.
Really good early education.
Helping to develop both your social skills
and your academic skills.
An academically rigorous school connected
to all the resources of the community.
A mentor to help guide the way.
And then, that pot of gold at the end of the
rainbow.
That's the hope.
That's the ideal.
And as I said, I mean, to me, it satisfies
for the broad majority of kids my Golden Rule
test.
It's pretty close to what I would wanna do
for my own kid.
It's affordable.
When I try to work out a budget, I was talking
about 60 billion dollars.
That sounds like a lot of money--maybe.
But again, in comparison to any of the measures
that are out there, not such a fortune.
If every American drank one fewer Coke a month,
we'd have a billion dollars a year to add
to the pot.
There's nothing partisan about this.
Kids aren't Republicans.
Kids aren't Democrats.
Kids are kids.
Parent's concern about kids cuts across lines
and so does their willingness to support kids.
And yet, we're at a point in which for every
dollar that goes to a kid, seven dollars goes
to a geezer like me.
And the reason for that is pretty clear.
Four-letter acronym.
First two letters are vowels.
Anybody wanna tell me what that four-letter
acronym is that explains why seniors do so
well?
>>MALE #1: AARP
>>David Kirp: AARP, right?
Seniors, 1960, were the poorest part of the
population.
Along comes AARP.
Mass membership.
Forty-five million members.
And what they have harped on is three items.
Seniors want social security, Medicare, prescription
drug benefits.
That is it.
Kid's advocates?
We don't have time to list all the things
that kid's advocates want.
They're badly organized.
They're fractious.
Politicians can get away with not paying any
attention to them.
The old political line is, "Kids don't matter
because kids don't vote."
And until there is some effort to organize
all the folks who are engaged and involved
with kids, in an effort that even vaguely
approaches the AARP, unless there's some way
to push/nudge the political system into rethinking
its priorities, investing in the next generation
and enabling families to be the good stewards
they want, then this becomes nothing more
than a nice conversation.
And I say that with particular poignancy here
because this is a group that is interested
in reshaping the universe in various ways
and has a set of tools that can be put to
use in the interest of kids.
And I hope that happens.
And we can talk more about what that would
mean.
But let me stop now and invite comments, questions,
thoughts, puzzles that you might have.
Yeah.
>>MALE #2: So, how is AARP successful?
And what won't stop, for example, groups of
parents--?
Would it require seniors who have a lot of
money to create this?
And instead invested [inaudible ] money, or--?
>>David Kirp: Yeah, it's an--.
>>Male Presenter: Can you repeat the question
into the mic?
>>David Kirp: Yeah.
The question is how did the AARP make it?
Which is a great question.
And the answer is that a group of organizations
got together, agreed on a platform, and decided
on a model, which was "we're gonna be a mass
organization, 15 bucks a years, and you're
a member of AARP."
You don't have to do anything.
So, when this organization starts growing
into the millions, when it shows up at the
bargaining table, people pay attention.
You will notice that despite all the brave
talk about cutting entitlement programs, which
means cutting Social Security and Medicare,
it hasn't happened.
And when a Republican Congressman was endorsing
serious Medicare cuts and transfers and was
kicked out of office in Buffalo this past
spring on that issue, people paid attention.
So, the agenda is simple.
The organizing principle is clear.
The institution mushrooms over a period of
time.
It would take kid's advocates sitting down
at a table and being willing to put aside
adult egos--really tough to do.
My program, my program, my program.
And saying, "OK.
For this year, this is what we're gonna focus
on."
And it can be at Washington.
It could be in Sacramento.
It can be in Mountain View.
Wherever.
These days, it's probably easier-- even despite
the state of economy here-- it's probably
easier to look at the local level than to
look at what's happening in Washington.
But it takes that kind of energy.
At the local level, it means you think about
the people who are involved in kid's lives,
you bring them together, you sit them down,
and you keep saying, "For the kids.
For the kids.
For the kids."
And eventually, they get engaged enough to
in fact, put aside what it is that their program
is about and think about how they can be more
powerful by combining with other forces.
That's what's required.
And it happens in some places.
My favorite story comes from Illinois where
for the last 30-odd years, the kid's organizations
really have come together.
And they have been able--.
They were one of the first states to get pre-school--
state pre-school--universal state pre-school.
Now, they were the first state to make sure
that that program included early pre-school.
Zero to three as well as three to five.
And they have a big child care program.
How did they do this?
They did this in the way I'm describing.
They get together.
They fight it out.
They come out and say, "This is what we're
about doing."
Every year, they send about 30, 40 thousand
parents.
They bus them to Springfield's state capitol
for Kid's Day.
And one mom from south side of Chicago buttonholes
her state Senator and says, "Senator, how
can we get more money for early education?"
And he said, "I wish I could help you, ma'am,
but there's nothing I can do."
And she said right back, "OK.
How can we elect somebody who can actually
do something?"
[laughter]
That's the attitude that's sorely lacking
and that we need to see more of.
Yeah.
>>MALE #3: So, if I look at the four points,
and I like the examples that I got from your
description of one, three and five, a pretty
good sense of what policies can support those
things.
>>David Kirp: Mm-hmm.
>>MALE #3: Could you elaborate more on policies
that could support two and four?
>>David Kirp: So, what policies could support
early education and mentoring?
OK.
Start with something that's happening in Washington
now.
And that is an Early Learning Challenge grant
program that the Administration has introduced.
A five hundred million dollar program.
And that program says to the states, "We want
you to build a system of supports from birth
to age five."
It's very much like what it was that I was
working on when I was on the Transition Team.
States develop a--.
You know where the gaps are.
You don't have good child care.
You don't have early education.
You don't have parenting programs.
So, we want high quality, public, private,
transparent, parent-engaged programs.
And I was not a great fan of Race to the Top
because of its incentives.
Here, the incentives are all in the right
direction.
More generally, there's a pretty effective--there
was--a pretty effective political push to
expand early education at the state level.
Even through the 2000s, as money was getting
tight, more money was being spent across the
states.
So now, about eight billion dollars is spent
as opposed to about two billion dollars seven
or eight years ago.
The problem is this, and here's where the
political difficulty arises.
Politicians are naturally credit claimers.
That's not an insult.
That's a description.
They need to be able to say, "I did this."
Right?
If they're gonna get elected again, "I did
this."
And it's a whole lot easier to say, "I added
50 thousand kids to the pre-school rolls,"
than it is to say, "I demanded better qualified
teachers, smaller classes, and evidence-based--."
The audience has gone away.
So, the task of the folks who are focused
on policy of early education is to start with
better and then move to bigger.
It's a whole lot easier to move from better
to bigger, politically, than it is to move
from bigger to better.
And that really again, means starting at the
local level and working out from there.
It also means making sure that the horrible
fight that goes on between early education
folks and child care folks comes to an end.
I mean, this is just ludicrous.
These guys are always at each other's throats.
It's as if education goes on from 8 to 1 and
then the kids are left free to do nothing.
Their brains just turn off.
It doesn't work that way, right?
And it's all about education.
And it's all about play.
But those guys have got to get it together.
Mentoring.
What's interesting now is as the Baby Boomers
turn 60 and older, ten thousand a day, ten
thousand people a day, turn 60 years old.
They say that they want to be involved in
giving back to the community.
They're not just wanting to play bridge and
golf and what have you.
And kids and the church are the highest two
items on their list.
So, tapping that untapped potential is really
a task.
Not just for government, but for private organizations,
I mentioned before an organization called
Experience Corps, which sends seniors into
the schools to tutor kids from Kindergarten
through 3rd grade.
Experience Corps, on whose board I sit.
So, they just merged with AARP.
It's a great example of what I mean when I
talk about taking a program and making it
a system.
Experience Corps is a lovely little program.
Ten thousand volunteers.
What, from my view, if you think about the
infrastructure that AARP has, we're talking
about a hundred thousand in five years and
growing.
AARP's point of view, they love it because
they're now branded as selfless seniors.
This is a way of doing well by doing good.
Their organization, it's actually spreading
its wings.
It doesn't have to be government.
Although, government can certainly fund, and
has funded, mentoring programs for kids, particularly
at risk.
The children of folks who are in prison.
The children of kids who were, in one way
or another, in trouble.
And the great thing to me about Big Brothers
Big Sisters though, is that it's open to everybody.
It's like universal pre-school.
It's like good parenting programs.
Anybody can sign up.
It's about "the poor."
It's not about "them" needing help.
I mean, this is a book.
This is a set of ideas that's meant to cut
across the spectrum--the income spectrum.
I spent a lot of time in my career thinking
about poor kids and special needs kids and
African American boys and their educational
problems.
So, I get the importance of particular needs.
I was a counsel in a case challenging a policy
in Texas in which a child who spoke Spanish
on the playground got suspended from school.
It's only 40 years ago that this happened.
But here, I wanted programs that would reach
systems that would reach across the spectrum.
For example, in terms of school readiness,
we know that poor kids come to school to Kindergarten
well behind middle-class kids.
What we don't know is that middle-class kids
are as far behind wealthy kids when they come
to school.
And the numbers are bigger.
So, here's a program whose general thrust
is what I'd call "selective universalism."
You focus first on poor families because their
needs are gonna be greatest.
But you really do think broadly.
I think it's politically much more feasible,
so that we're talking about us, not them.
And I think it's ethically preferable to have
a world in which we really are not thinking
about just the poor, but we're thinking what
it is that society as a whole could benefit
from and needs.
Yeah.
>>MALE #4: I noticed one of the five things
that you don't talk about, or one of the things
you don't talk about in the five things is
the quality of the education itself.
Why isn't this topic in the book?
>>David Kirp: Well, it's a great question.
>>[audience member coughs]
>>David Kirp: And why didn't I talk about
the quality of education in the book?
Because we're stuck in this sterile debate
about what quality means.
Is it all about accountability and test results
and firing teachers and charter schools?
Is it about giving teachers lots of support,
etc.?
There is a ton of stuff out.
That's the conversation.
And as I say, I posit in this book that rigorous
academic programs are essential for kids--all
kids.
I just--.
People pick an argument about that.
I don't see that.
You can't solve the education problems of
this country with charter schools.
Not with 60 million kids and 3 million teachers.
You're just not gonna be able to do it, whatever
you think about charter schools.
You've gotta work within public schools.
And public schools are the only institution,
along with churches and libraries, that are
in all communities.
They become a base for what you're doing.
But I just didn't see any reason to enter
that fray.
It's a pretty well-worn area.
And frankly, I don't think anybody's--.
People's minds are made up by now.
There's enough stuff out there about get rid
of the unions, or the charter schools are
really draining resources from our public
schools.
So, I quite deliberately said, "I wanna look
at all the things that aren't just about 8
to 3, literacy and numeracy."
That's the world that nobody is talking about
these days.
>>MALE #5: [ inaudible ] books.
Was there--?
What was your issue with parents who can't
send their kids
to charter school who don't feel well, at
least I want our kids to get the best education
they can, don't feel like they can save the
whole world [ inaudible ], but perhaps is
there a pitch that you could make that would
provide the [ inaudible ] to try to get the
best solution for them?
>>David Kirp: I think for parents, it's tough.
Parents are fundamentally conservative when
it comes to their own kids.
We have all sorts of great ideas for changing
society.
For our kids, we see this narrow pyramid of
what success looks like and all the failures
along the way, or seeming failures along the
way.
They wanna give kids every advantage.
I think if you look inside public schools--and
I'm spending a lot of time these days in poor,
urban, Latino school district just outside
of New York City.
The most crowded city in the country.
Those schools satisfy my Golden Rule test.
And I found brilliant teachers there.
So, one of the things I'd say to parents is
check your prejudices, walk into the public
school, see what's going on.
The other thing I would say is your child
is gonna be exposed not just in the 8 to 3,
180-day year, but all the time, to ideas.
There are books in the house, right?
You're having conversations at the dinner
table.
You listen to middle-class families when they're
on Muni in San Francisco talking to their
kids.
They're always talking to their kids.
"What's that out there?
What do we call that?
Do you like that?"
It's always education going on.
So, I think people fetishize the elite schools.
Certainly when it comes to pre-schools.
Not needed to spend 25 thousand dollars a
year to get a good pre-school education for
your kids.
And I think that's the hype, danger hysteria.
I think it's hard to ask parents--particularly
parents of young children, to get very politically
engaged because their lives are consumed with
making a living and raising their children.
But it's not hard to get grandparents involved
because they do have the time and they have
the perspective.
And I've seen wonderful examples where grandparents
get engaged politically, for example, where
in a very conservative congressional district--the
district that's the home to George Bush's
ranch in Texas.
The odds on favorite to win congressional
elections, somebody who'd been schooled by
Karl Rove, who had a ton of money lost because
she had bragged that she had saved the state
a billion dollars by cutting kids off the
state's health rolls.
All it took was one TV commercial.
A kind of Walker Evans photograph of a mom
with her kid--her nine-year old kid--and the
mom, who was a widow, was saying, "I love
my child, but if she gets sick I don't know
what I'm gonna do because now I don't have
any health insurance because of what's happened."
That's all it took for a bunch of very conservative,
particularly women and particularly grandmas,
to vote Democrat once in their lives.
So again, this is not a partisan pitch.
This is not a partisan set of ideas.
I think the Republicans would expand their
appeal enormously if they realized how broad-based
the support is for kid's programs.
But for people who are either in their 20s
and not yet having families, or people who
are in their 50s and 60s and their kids are
out the door, there's lots of room for supporting
them on this.
Also, for all those folks who work in kid-serving
organizations--the social workers, the teachers,
and the librarians, and the nurses, etc.--they're
all involved in kid's lives.
And they're doing amazing work, but if could
also be thinking in policy terms and politics
terms and not just "what I'm doing in the
classroom."
with a little bit of their lives, they'd make
an enormous difference in the conversation.
Do I see a hand back there?
Yeah.
>>MALE #6: So, what can individual people
do at the national level to support [inaudible
]?
>>David Kirp: I think the most useful thing
to do, and I'm thinking aloud on these questions,
is to get involved.
If there's a political campaign for a national
office, particularly Congress, that pits somebody
who's got a record of being effectively anti-kid,
against the challenger, to be engaged in that
campaign is hugely important.
The reason for that is pretty simple.
Politicians are risk-adverse folks.
They see a few politicians go down in defeat
on kid's issues, they're gonna change their
tune.
So, to take the aftermath of my Texas story
was the Texas legislature convenes that January
and the first thing it does, the first thing
it does, is restore those kid's health cuts.
They got it.
So, that would be idea number one.
And I would, when it comes to organizations,
there is nothing that really spans this terrain.
So, I would say you look for groups that are
doing either good substantive work, good research
work, or good policy work on behalf of particular
groups of kids.
I think that beyond the political universe,
people's energies are much better focused
at the state and local level.
Because that, right now, given what's happening--that
circus in Washington--things are much more
likely to happen in Mountain View than they
are in Congress.
And I hope that happens.
And I hope--it's a good last question--I hope
that you all think about ways that you can
use the talents that you have and the talents
this organization has to work for the interest
of kids.
These are your--very crassly put--these are
your future consumers, future users.
It would be nice if they were more able and
adept at being able to play both of those
roles.
They're also your own children and your neighbor's
children, so they matter on that basis as
well.
Thank you.
[applause]